Now that you've gotten some practice with multiplying rational expressions,
let's move on to dividing rational expressions. And instead of diving right into
dividing rational expressions, let's start with what we know, dividing
fractions. If we want to divide by a fraction, we really multiply it by the
reciprocal of that fraction. So three-sevenths divided by two-sevenths would be
three-sevenths times seven-halves. We cancel the factors in the numerator,
denominator which leaves us with three halves. We divide rational expressions
the same way that we divide fractions. We're going to change division to
multiplication and multiply by the reciprocal. So try doing this rational
expression problem. Change the division to multiplication and multiply by the
reciprocal of this fraction. Make sure you find the cube of 2t before you
multiply. When you think you've got it, write your answer as a fraction here.